old bed sheets like this don't cut it
anymore Americans will spend more than
$2.6 billion dollar on Halloween
costumes this year and those with the
deepest pockets in Manhattan come here
to Abracadabra in this area there a lot
of alent people and they want a good
costume so you're not going to get these
costumes in this pop-up
stores aad is three floors of Halloween
Madness we're at 13,000 ft here so this
particular corner here is what we got
for kids the rest of the store is all
adult it's insane this Halloween
playground has masks and hats props a
magic shop its own makeup line and of
course a wig Salon I'm going to need to
try a wig on I'm wigging out I mean oh
that looks good abcab wigs cost up to
250 bucks but its real money makers are
handmade costumes that I had to try on I
want to go downstairs let's go highend
come
on I'd like you to pick something for me
to try on you sure I'm sure you
positive positive I don't think she can
handle
it we need more material than this this
is not enough clothing for me I'm in
daytime TV not prime time he was right I
couldn't handle it I want to see the
custom Elsa costume you've got when
Disney's Elsa costume went on sale
36,000 were sold in its first day but
this isn't the package version to buy
this it's 1,700 bucks it's all handmade
everything did my wedding dress cost
1,700 bucks I think your costume should
reflect your spirit and for me I'm a
little more Maleficent than I am else
yeah I think so this is $3,600 to sell
3600 bucks to buy this bad boy
I had to try it on
$3600 of
Maleficent sounds good to me well
well